alright so i'll talk about stock market
structure and hopefully changing it so
that we can use MPC beneficially to help
the stock market structure and i'm
obviously by no means an expert in
finance so so if you have too hard a
question I may have to you know postpone
it for a year to answer it so but
hopefully things will go where all right
so this is the talk outline so we will
first discuss what's the exact purpose
of stock market all right and then is
there a problem with the stock market in
okay and then we will do some eco 101
kind of crash course hopefully it will
be only one slide and then this is where
it gets more interesting because we are
trying to model information in
equilibrium pricing all right and since
in cryptography we basically deal with
information and about privacy of
information so that's where you know we
bring in our expertise all right
hopefully and then we'll just discuss
some price discovery mechanisms and
we'll talk about this novel structural
stock market which turns out it's
actually antiquated it was used way
before you know we were around so and
then we'll do some more analysis of more
of an illustrative kind than any
comprehensive theorems anything like
that so so it is mostly to show that
with MPC I mean we can change the
structure back to what it used to be all
right and over the years or over the
centuries it has taken a wrong trend
basically and mostly because if you ask
economics grad student for instance I
mean for them you know the idea of MPC
is just inconceivable all right so so
hopefully like we bring in our expertise
and we can change things
for the better ok so the stock market
basically has two purposes one is price
discovery and another is liquidity
alright so price discovery is important
because everybody needs to know what the
price is because you want to make an
investment you should have some idea
what the prices and so in a more
abstract sense what it really is in
economics people study price discovery
because it kind of gathers all the
individual piece of information which is
all over the world people have something
in their mind they don't really know but
somehow the pricing mechanism discovers
the price and it helps everybody make a
joint decision as to how to invest their
money or the capital which is around
alright so price discovery is really
important and this is how the economy
works it's been going on for ages price
discovery has been going on even before
people understood that price discovery
is going on alright so it's like very
fundamental human trait and or a
collective human trait liquidity is is
basically saying that there is a market
out there alright if you want to dispose
of of your assets it should be done as
quickly but in a reasonable amount of
time without distorting the market right
so for instance the Apple stock right
now is very liquid you want to sell a
million shares no problem there will be
enough people ready to buy it right away
all right but if you want to sell tulips
all right yeah IBM and there may be one
or two people is still willing to buy it
okay so there are two kinds of stock
markets all right there are many kinds
of stock market but mostly we are
familiar with the New York Stock
Exchange and the nasdaq all right then
both of them run what's called double
options basically buyers are in there
and the sellers are in their biases
putting in their orders to buy stuff and
the sellers one
sell stuff and some kind of matching
happens and there is a clearing and you
know the price is discovered and trade
happens all right so the main difference
between nicey and Nasdaq they're both
double auctions but the nice new york
stock scene is obviously more
traditional it's been around for a much
much longer time it is that there is a
specialist for each stock is like a
special auctioneer who will collect your
bids and asks and keep them secret all
right he will not disclose the bits and
asked to people he will just clear the
market and announce the trades all right
whereas on NASDAQ it's a centralized
repository of like a computerized
repository where everybody's bits and
Oscar in the tier and then trade happens
in the clear alright so that's the main
difference and Nasdaq is the newer one
and apparently even nicey is moving
towards this other trend so what exactly
is going on so I think the main reason
is that basically the specialist is not
really trusted all right so you can put
your buy orders in there if you want to
sell million shares of IBM for instance
that's a disaster for you all right
because the specialist licks it all
right the shears are going to drop
radically all right yeah oh so okay so
so the New York Stock Exchange's is like
a clearing price auction all right in
the beginning of a day all right the
first opening price is discovered using
a clearing price option then during the
day it's more of a continuous straight
but it is still the bids and ask is
still hidden you there with the
specialist whereas in I see in Nasdaq
there is no clearing price auction it's
called the continuous double action all
right the midst and ass are out there in
a cable in the repository the new ones
come in as soon as the match they
cleared and so on all right so so there
is a problem basically because the
specialist is not trusted all right so
the trend is towards the open system if
you don't trust especially my might as
well go with the open system and what
people do is if they have a huge order
to sell
they do all kind of hiding strategies
okay they will sell thousand and maybe
buy a hundred back so that nobody knows
what they're doing so it's all
complicated they're all kind of
algorithms out there so that's why there
is this chaotic trading going on day in
and day out alright so that's what it is
and then there are these high frequency
traders who have written algorithms they
just sense the bids and asks in the
market in the open all right and they
try to figure out figure out from that
whether you have some special
information all right so so these are
the problems basically okay so now can
you model all these things all right so
obviously you know this is what you
learn in your economics first first
course in economics you know there is
this demand curve and there is a supply
curve all right these are the prices and
are and that's the amount of demand so
at at price one there's a lot of demand
but not many people are willing to sell
all right and price for a lot of people
are willing to sell but there's not much
demand so that's like a clearing price
so that's the current price for that
commodity or exit for a particular
single commodity all right so we all
know this okay but what we really want
to study is more interesting scenarios
where there are multiple commodities all
sorts of assets people have how is an
equilibrium defined in such a situation
and and well race is a French economist
who were bagging 1877 formalize this
notion is called of all ratio in
equilibrium there are n resources & M
agents and each let's say we start out
with each agent having some of those
assets okay that's their endowment all
right so each one has some assets which
are like the agent I has eia of the jet
asset all right each agent also is a
utility function of the total wealth all
right so normally we know that you know
as as as your wealth goes up you know
your utility
and grow linearly right in fact it's an
exponential curve like that all right so
for most people like us it goes very
sharply up and then just stagnates there
we don't want too much money all right
but big institutions like mutual funds
which pool resources they are more
linear alright so those forms are called
risk neutral all right whereas we are
risk-averse all right so so that's a
very important characteristic to
remember there is what is called a risk
aversion coefficient alright so for
individuals like us the risk aversion
coefficient is very high all right
whereas for large firms it's close to
zero so that comes into factor later so
i just want to remind your pad so that's
what an economy is all right there's the
utility function of all the people or
all the agents and then this is their
endowment it's a vector of you can eat
it too eii as the vector you know think
of their endowment in all the J
components alright so that's the economy
to start with now what is in equilibrium
alright so first of all each individual
tries to optimize their assets so let's
assume that the prices for all the
assets are given to you all right
somehow prices have been decided all the
prices are given to you all right so so
let's say there's a vector of prices
market prices all right so based on
those market prices each agent tries to
maximize their utility alright so the
agent X I will want to find and Dow
different allotments for his different
resources he started off like this but
he want to go there all right and as
long as you know his total money is less
than what he started with he wants to
optimize the utility he gets from these
X I now instead of E I all right so he
wants to maximize the utility under this
constraint alright because he doesn't I
can't just generate well sort of know
so that's what a wall raised in
equilibrium is okay so you start off
with an economy where there's utility
function and then Dow ends then an
equilibrium says there is a market price
for each of the assets or commodities
and there's a redistribution now which
which satisfy these two properties okay
first of all each agent has maximized
their utility okay using this and that
and the market is clear alright so the
trade happens the sum total of each of
the assets remains as before so that's
called a walrus in equilibrium alright
and that's a very fundamental thing this
basically says that if F equilibrium
existed this would be the prices in the
world right now all right based on their
current utility okay so now the question
is how do you find this equilibrium okay
so wall Reyes actually suggested a
process called the Tomah okay it's a
French word so he suggested that
basically everybody submit their bids
and asks given the current prices okay
he will do a clearing and the lien
announced a new set of prices no trade
will happen but it will just announced a
new set of prices everybody based on
that now submit resubmit their bids and
asks then again he does the same pricing
it continues forever and ever and ever
till an equilibrium is reached all
rights it's an endless trial and error
process in the end when the prices are
convergent then the trade happens okay
so this is called the Thoman actually
it's a French word for groping all right
so only the French can come up with such
a nice word
just a really good buy so much I know
this is like a preliminary prices let's
say from yesterday it's a nightlight
people will say okay for this price I
want this much shares and for this
person I want to sell that much and they
can have all kind of combinations all
right yeah so that was based on the
previous day's price things have changed
there's more information in the world
all right so now they want to find the
new price alright so this process is
like seemingly endless all right but and
in fact it can be shown like there have
been papers written on it that this plus
it doesn't even converge all right there
are instances of endowments and utility
functions where it may not converge this
process all right but the stock market's
to think about it they're basically
trying to do this all right this is
what's happening in the stock market
except the traits do happen but those
are small amounts all right in the end
effectively over a whole day's process
there is this price discovered for each
of the commodities or the Starks and
there is some final total net trade
happen so it is an approximation to
resettlement process only problem with
it is in the Nash textile market the
bids and asks are open the entertainment
the specialist is not supposed to reveal
the bitterness he's only supposed to
reveal the price at each instance for
the resubmission of your bits and ask so
it's a very loose kind of an
approximation which really doesn't work
all right but people are still trying it
okay for lack of anything better I guess
but wait so there are more problems here
alright so in 1980 Grossman and stylist
they wrote a paper which is titled
impossibility of informational e
efficient markets okay so till now we
didn't bring information into the
picture information was not being traded
there is no price involved with it it
was just commodities okay
so so in in finance there is this whole
notion of called efficient markets
theory with what it says is that
basically the price will tell you all
the information you need to know the
price of all the assets already capture
all the information but what these two
authors have shown that that's not true
all right so let's see okay so there are
these informed traders they have done
some research they spent a lot of money
on it and they gathered a lot of
important information all right and but
if the price is already incorporating
their information they get no incentive
in the final settlement process all
right because their information is
already in captured in the pricing all
right so they can't be incentivized so
they will stop doing research all right
they spent a lot of money on it okay so
they will get rid of doing any research
so the equilibrium will be no one is
doing any research all right or the
so-called equilibrium all right but
that's not an equilibrium because at
least one guy will figure that if I do
some more research I can benefit a lot
all right so in the information economy
this Val ratio in equilibrium as but at
least the water is in equilibrium is
fine but this efficient market
hypothesis is actually invalid all right
that the price reflects all the
information that is wrong all right so
there is actually a model for this
alright so in 2004 these two professors
from Cornell they came up with the model
where they want to show that the price
actually does not show all the
information all right and then basically
they say that there is a valuation
equilibrium if you do it correctly then
the price doesn't reflect everything all
right but of course importantly that in
this water is in equilibrium the bits
and asks need to be hidden during the
process all right if you reveal the bits
and ass also that will give out your
information all right then you'll have
no incentive alright so that's the
important thing to remember here is it
what does it mean that the price
contains all the information well
basically it says that you can simulate
our everything based on your price all
the assets all right yeah oh and let's
not get there alright so that was saying
basically the price contains all the
information so it just it doesn't even
have to be recursive it's just
information 30 alright so that's the
Assumption obviously well everybody's
utility okay so one thing in lot of this
thing is that lot of public parameters
are are already known a priori for
example everybody's utility function is
known let us say all right now you want
to know what their valuation of a
particular asset is on that particular
day that's the information it's saying
it's revealed alright so that's the
critical information so from the prices
of all the assets and given that you
know everybody utility function you can
calculate backwards like using Batian
rule okay what the valuation of each
individual is for each asset alright
that's what it is but when information
comes into the play that is no more the
case alright so this model actually will
try to show that all right so how does
this model work
or so so all the things in the blue will
be public knowledge all right so the way
the public knowledge works is that
that's a very interesting thing from our
privacy preserving notions that we have
all right basically they are saying that
everything is is public anyway all right
so in a way that's why Hugh and me we
always have this trouble that how come
people are not interested in privacy but
maybe they follow this general
equilibrium theory and think that
everything is out there anyway all right
so so this the aisle in this slide all
the blue things is let's say our public
knowledge all right so everybody knows
what the future distribution let's say
for tomorrow for apple stock or even
four month out is okay so it's a normal
distribution with mean hundred fifty and
variates 50 or something like that so
will be denoted by the random variable
is V and its average is V Bar and
variance is Rho ok so that's public
knowledge alright and all buyers are
risk covers you know their utility
functions you know what risk aversion
coefficient each of the buyer says you
know all those things okay you also know
the daily per capita supply of stock or
at least its distribution all right
which is you know the mean and it's
variants you also know the total number
of bias you also know the fraction of
the informed buyers who actually do
research all right the only thing you
don't know is that the informed buyers
will get a private signal okay s but
it's mean and variance you still know
all right and it's again a normal
distribution it may slightly be more
Pete all right so over here it was
normal with mean 150 and variance 50
this one will actually have the mean of
the actual random variable which is
about to show up next day all right but
it will still have a variance and that's
very important okay that this variance
still be there as we will see all right
this this variance is extremely
important that it is
they're okay
so of course you know you can you can
calculate the conditional probability of
a given the signal at least the informed
buyer scale all right and it will turn
out that it is also a normal
distribution just with a slightly better
variance okay so the normal curve got
squished all right and it's it's mean
has also shifted little bit towards the
signal all right so initially it was V
Bar and you got a signal s now suddenly
using Bayes rule you can calculate that
you know the mean is around here and the
variance is slightly squished the curve
is squished alright so that's good news
alright so what you can show under this
model and easily an O Hara show that
when you do the valuation equilibrium
price for this that price will only
reveal s partially it will not reveal s
completely alright so that's very good
news because the in-form traders have
any have a incentive to do research
because their information is more
precise than what can be revealed from
the price alright this is a really nice
piece of work okay and using gaussian
sand all wheel of gaussian so so and of
course i want to remind you that in this
walrus in equilibrium that you discover
it is very critical that the bids are
hidden because otherwise this partial
will become complete information for
everybody alright so then there's no
incentive all right
and the uninformed also get a return you
don't want to clearly completely throw
them out of the market all right so then
who are you going to sell to okay so so
the uninformed still get a return
because you're risk-averse and your
information has a variance all right you
you don't really know whether that
signal s will accurate or not all right
so there is some variance in it so you
leave something on the table for the
uninformed in fact the onion form can
just come in and buy it market price all
right and because you are basically the
big player because you did all the
research you'll be setting the prices
and the other uninformed like me and you
can just go in and put market orders and
we'll still get something all right so
here is the clearing price double option
that we propose should be the stock
market all right and this as I said
before it used to be the case that in
fact even now the opening of each stock
in new york stock exchange happens this
way more or less except that the
specialist is a human being or a firm
all right and they see all your bits and
asks here we're going to replace
everything with MPC all right and now
i'm not going to say which MPC
instantiation to use so there are lot of
versions and lot of experts in this room
and so and and then of course one of the
research topics here is that what else
can you leak all right so that you can
make it efficient and still incentivize
they informed all right because as you
will see in this one with some leakage
you can make it much more efficient and
if you want to hide everything possible
it's obviously really difficult alright
so the first thing obviously like we do
in cryptography is we will reveal the
total number of orders because if you
don't even reveal that that's really
difficult alright so most likely with
that no information is really late all
right now since I am running out of time
when one question which is so you're
saying that the current system where
you're revealing bids and asks that yes
off the other it is people who have done
research it's disincentivize to do
research right but reality seems to
contradict that's right what percentage
of going
no they are the high-frequency trade
their not really researching the stock
they are researching how you're trading
that's a different kind of research
which is not really useful research or
you want to do research about how
capital should be spent on which
efficient companies that's the research
I'm talking about all right those guys
and also by the way even if they are
making money it just means that you need
to pay them money to use that
information so that you can spend your
capital better all right so you need to
join the ranks it's not like you want to
get away from them all right so if
everybody does research it's actually
good because the equilibrium pricing
will be more faster to converge all
right so then assets will be allocated
more efficiently much faster all right
as opposed to just you know doing this
grouping process all right research is
the right answer yeah then that's the
distributions okay so the normal
distribution is there not every time you
will do the right answer and then of
course its collective it's not one
person that's also true yeah so these
are kind of philosophical questions it
can be debated the option here with your
computation write this so everybody who
wants it's everybody who wants to buy or
sell apple store for everybody who wants
to buy or sell a specific any stuff okay
so there are different versions of this
I mean we can think of no no so it will
be again like usual like like you know
they do for those sugar beets you know
there will be certain agents brokers and
then there will be five trusted parties
let's say so we'll go through those
right so not everybody is going to talk
to
well this one is very simple basically
it is very similar to the sugar beets
auction all right so except that you
know we allow market price orders and
then the pricing clearing mechanism is
slightly different from the sugar beets
all right and because we want to make
sure that the market orders are
completely allocated okay in every
clearing all right so that's one
requirement because you know you don't
want the market orders not to be
allocated there will be partial
allocation for some of those things
that's a tricky one that's what I'm
talking about there's some research
issues here what do you do about the
leakage in the partial allocation is the
probability leaked and does that leak
more information about the signal or not
there are a whole bunch of issues like
that so it's a mix of finance and how to
make things efficient all right so i
think my paper is online on ePrint since
yesterday so there are more such details
there so obviously i don't have much
time and I think I'll just like to stop
now
that was anything like yes exactly so
this is different this I'm trying to
show that it is actually even more
important yeah well you can you can do
this for let's say the S&P futures all
right which is one of the most important
things traded in the market and most
experts deal with that so we can start
with that